you know out there at the same time as
Aaron Rodgers but when that happened how
did you feel it was weird because like
even prior to the game going into it you
know you kind of felt the energy you
felt everything going into it it was
exciting and we kind of felt like The
Underdogs where uh Aaron Rodgers being
at the helm over there United being at a
disadvantage of anything but it was
going to make the game real interesting
added another element like this game's
gonna be good I mean the atmosphere was
crazy man and then it was it was flat
when it went down I'm a big proponent of
grass but this it didn't matter if it
was grass or turf the position that he
was in you know he had Leonard Floyd on
his waist 250 pounds that particular
injury it didn't matter if it was grass
or turf that that would have happened
what about Gary Wilson that was another
piece of me that kind of felt from when
Aaron Rodgers got hurt because it was
going to be interesting to see his
second year jump with an established
quarterback not that anybody can't throw
him in the ball but you know it's a
little different when you got a Hall of
Fame guy back there slinging that thing
around being a fan of football of course
you want Aaron Rodgers out there you
know he's an opponent and all but I love
competition out there too man